une harmonie de surface qui cache un
duel de titans
celui entre les deux plus importantes
économies du monde
la chine veut renforcer son influence
dans la région
elle est omniprésente à port moresby
capitale de la papouasie nouvelle guinée
le pays est le plus pauvre de l'apec
cette nouvelle route et le centre de
conférence c'est la chine qui les a
construits ce logo
il est presque partout le président
chinois s'est présenté en défenseur du
libre commerce international il a mis le
monde en garde contre le protectionnisme
celui qui se ferme aux autres perdra le
monde at il affirmé
une pointe à l'unilatéralisme américain
vice président des états unis
rétorque avec un avertissement attention
dit il de ne pas tomber dans le piège
chinois pékin prête des sommes
colossales pour des projets
d'infrastructure à des états qui n'ont
pas toujours les moyens de les
rembourser
2 ne laissez pas les dettes étrangères
compromettre votre souveraineté
washington n'a pas l'intention non plus
de retirer les tarifs douaniers imposé à
plus de 250 milliards de dollars de
produits chinois pourrions même double
ici tarifs menace-t-il
pendant ce temps le premier ministre du
canada a discuté avec les dirigeants des
petites îles du pacifique
le canada aussi veut jouer un rôle dans
la région et justin trudeau fait le pari
qu'il pourra obtenir une part
d'influencé en misant sur la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
le libre-échange occupera une grande
partie de l'agenda de justin trudeau
dimanche le premier ministre doit
s'entretenir avec ses homologues
japonais et australiens deux signataires
du partenariat transpacifique cet accord
de libre échange qui doit entrer en
vigueur en partie vers la fin de l'année
il s'y fait de bon sens foisy radio
canada par moresby papouasie nouvelle
guinée